[Applause]
here we go folks
I'm excited the salt of the earth you
obviously haven't met him then why you
know what I don't need to meet this guy
because I know
[Music]
is absolutely has that same attitude
never lost her words
highly intelligent and by god he loves
instead oh man time to limit approaching
the ring first
probably you long gone let into your
sixteen pounds
[Music]
and I don't blame I look at this guy
coming out with a nice music shut my
music cut my music
[Applause]
[Music]
so self-satisfied
[Applause]
[Music]
gotta let the man speak back to being
shoved in lockers again I'm so sorry
that must be awful
pipe down guys pipe down I'm gonna try
to make you guys feel it
[Applause]
I'm gonna try to make you guys feel as
comfortable as possible in your own skin
okay so how about I give you nerds
something I know you're gonna love
[Applause]
that mother of yours whose basement you
live in she swallows so hate to break it
to you doc hate to break it to you
little pop quiz here for you nerds what
happens when you got a dollar store
Tarzan a 65 year old grown man who's
still in his evil phase from high school
and Seabiscuit in the ring against the
youngest and fastest rising star in
professional wrestling today
Maxwell Jacob Freedman
[Applause]
you get em Jo getting the W baby
are you guys seriously going to talk
while I'm talking what is actually I'm
Jam I'm a level 45 Padawan warlike night
so you better watch your mouth
news flash you pencil neck geeks if I
wanted to hear your opinions I would
turn on TLC and watch reruns of my
600-pound life so shut up
those gaming terms don't really connect
but don't let it bullet slide you know
what you know what we're getting off on
the wrong foot here in Florida and I'm
sorry I'm sorry listen listen allow them
to an extend an olive branch because as
we all know I am salt of the earth I
[Applause]
want you people to know we're not so
different you and I I used to love video
games yeah video games video games yeah
I love video games and then I lost my
virginity
and that's one get a wink tonight baby
because I'm better than you and you know
it
[Applause]
[Music]